[inaudible] you probably watch,
listen to or at the very least heard about
Joe Rogan's interview with tech giant
Elon Musk from last week.
Joe and Alan had a wide ranging
discussion for two and a half hours about
evolution,
technology,
market simulation theory and much more
immediately after though the headlines
were all about the blunt that they smoked
in the last 20 minutes along with the
very memorable image of Alon
with smoke surrounding his head.
Shortly after aligns Rogan interview
aired two topic Tesla executives resigned
and Tesla stock dropped significantly.
The usual suspects wrote, think pieces,
questioning whether Musk was mentally
stable or fit to be an executive at the
very company he created.
I think the majority of people found
the whole ordeal to be kind of funny and
Quirky. You know, like a surprising moment
that makes life kind of interesting,
but apparently these days if
you do anything that doesn't
conform to group thing,
there's a media click machine that'll
see blood and is waiting to strike.
Now first off, we'd is totally,
completely 100% legal here in California.
I'm guessing that you person watching
this right now have probably tried it once
or twice yourself,
maybe even inhaled,
but perhaps more importantly than legal
issue or whether marijuana has health
benefits, impairs your judgment
or all of the above lies.
A more important question,
Alon Musk may be a little nutty,
but is unquestionably one of the most
important visionaries we have today beyond
Tesla, his electric car company, which
is revolutionize the automobile industry.
He's also the founder and CEO of space x,
which is sending rockets beyond Earth's
orbit and will most likely make life on
Mars a reality within our lifetime.
If that's not enough.
His ironically named boring company is
building tunnels under Los Angeles and an
attempt to relieve Las infamously
insane traffic. In short,
alon isn't just changing
the world for the better.
He's creating the reality of a future
that most people can only dream of.
While the Alon marijuana memes were great,
they overshadow the conversation with
one of the few modern visionaries we have
left. As Tesla employees stepped down
or traders worry about Musk's behavior.
Perhaps it's just this
adventure is attitude,
which allows Musk to solve problems.
While most people just complain,
think the automobile industry is moving
on electric cars to slowly create Tesla.
Think NASA is in exploring space
fast enough, start space x.
While we all talk a few people
actually do, and for those who do,
maybe being different isn't a flaw in
the system. It's part of the design.
Since when do we live in a time when
our geniuses can't have idiosyncratic
quirks or act out in ways that make
them stand apart from the rest of us are
inventors need the room to be different
because that different way of thinking
is where they find the spark that ignites
their genius. With all this in mind,
let's shift to the very company
which put a line on the map.
He cocreated paypal alongside another
misunderstood tech giant Peter Teal Teal.
The guy on the left in this picture is
an entrepreneur, venture capitalists,
philanthropist, author, and my
guest on the Rubin report this week.
Perhaps even more than MUSC. Teal
seems to be misunderstood by the media,
which seems more interested in him
as a caricature than as a person.
Over the last two years,
I've become friends with Peter through
his friend and my friend and confidant,
Eric Weinstein. I know Peter to
be an open, decent, thoughtful,
curious person.
Someone who privately is all of the
things that the media says he is not,
and that's the person I hope to introduce
you to today. Beyond founding paypal,
teal was also the first outside investor
in Facebook who turned $500,000 into
considerably more than that.
He also funded Hulk Hogan's lawsuit,
which ultimately toppled
Gawker, uh, move many things,
was an attack against the media,
but I believe to be a seminal moment
in defense of the fourth amendment,
which defended our right to privacy.
Peter has become the ultimate contrarian
in the tech world of Silicon Valley,
which has become stagnant and dull.
When's the last time you were really
excited about a new APP for your phone?
Remember when there was a new app
every day that you just had to have?
Those days seem to be long gone
and Peter sees a reason for it.
He has long talked about the dangers of
group think and Foad diversity to have
the idea destroying forces which
have taken over the tech world.
That's exactly why his recent move
from Silicon Valley to Los Angeles has
happened. Yeah, that's right.
La is suddenly becoming a home of free
thought thanks to the creatively crushing
progressive orthodoxy that
has taken over Silicon Valley.
We live in strange times.
Indeed.
Peter was also the person with the highest
profile in the tech world to support
Donald Trump for president and even spoke
at the Republican National Convention
when he told a room full of Republicans
that he was proud to be gay.
He received a thunderous round of
applause and I remember thinking how that
moment was a powerful shift in the
democratic lock on Gay Americans and the
beginning of a new, perhaps more
tolerant Republican party deal.
I had no idea if he was going to
get booed or cheered at that moment,
but I believe that the new libertarian
view the Republican party has taken on
marriage equality is in large part
because Peter Dare to stand up for what he
believed in,
even if it was against
conservative orthodoxy with
so much in flux in the world
right now,
people like Alon and Peter have more of
a chance to shape the future than ever
before.
As old institutions continue to crumble,
we need new visionaries to build
us the institutions of the future.
If they're quirky or misunderstood,
then they're probably exactly the
people we need to get the job done.